und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein 100 tage sind nichts
in der geschichte dieses planeten 100
tage sind 100 zu viel wenn jeder
einzelne von ihnen zerstörung bringt
qualen und leid 100 tage lang dauert der
russische krieg gegen die ukraine nun
schon und er ist nicht vorbei wir nehmen
diesen moment heute abend zum anlass um
genau hinzusehen was passiert ist was
noch droht und was die vergangenen 100
tage jetzt schon unwiederbringlich
verändert haben für die ukraine für die
welt für uns in deutschland wir beginnen
mit drei bildern das war das theater das
ist das theater in mariupol ein
shoppingcenter in kiel vorher und
nachher
zwischen zukunftsaussichten und der
apokalypse zwischen leben und tod die
stadt summe aus der luft was 100 tage
krieg anrichten dalian
in maribor leben sie jetzt unter
russischer herrschaft nach drei monaten
belagerung und beschuss wen hier
russische fahnen läuft russische
propaganda russische normalität für den
andere einen hohen preis zahlen mussten
vor der stadt massengräber und
mittendrin valeria mit china dort wo ihr
mann begraben ist
sie liegen einer über dem anderen in
acht schichten drei nebeneinander
was machen 100 tage krieg mit einem land
und seinen menschen
die un spricht von
4169 getöteten zivilisten darunter zwei
168 kinder die wirklichen zahlen liegen
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher dazu
kommen tausende getötete soldaten rund
acht millionen menschen flohen innerhalb
der ukraine mehr als 6,8 millionen
verließen ihre heimat
[Musik]
rückblick es ist der 24
februar
2022 russische einheiten fallen in die
ukraine ein
das ziel kiew einnehmen und die
regierung stürzen das ganze land steht
unter beschuss doch der russische
vormarsch im norden stockte ukraine
soldaten nicht nur von den russen lange
unterschätzt die kleinen mobilen
einheiten der ukrainischen armee agieren
offenbar moderner als die schwerfälligen
truppen russlands und die ukraine ist
vorbereitet beispiel kiew bestellte vor
dem krieg kampfstarke drohnen aus
türkischer produktion die für einen teil
des erfolgs der ukraine verantwortlich
gemacht werden die russen konzentrieren
sich auf den osten des landes ziehen
sich aus dem norden zurück die einnahme
des dollars habe bedingungslose
priorität
wo die russischen truppen abziehen
werden kriegsverbrechen bekannt wie in
butter 20 kilometer vorher es bleibt
nicht die einzige stadt
erst jetzt erreichen die russischen
truppen strategische ziele mittlerweile
kontrollieren sie 20 prozent der ukraine
darunter wichtige städte wie mario pohl
und carson städte wie odessa haake von
kiew sind immer wieder ziele russische
angriffe
die starts here veron jetzt ist fast
komplett russisch gesetzt die
vollständige einnahme der provinz lohans
rückt damit näher am tag 100 eines
zermürbenden krieges bleibt die
erkenntnis ein untertage krieg das sind
100 tage leid zerstörung und ein land
das nicht aufgeben will
es gibt viele geschehnisse geschichten
gesichter die sich eingebrannt haben in
den letzten hundert tagen ihnen zu hause
wird das so gehen uns hier auch diese
momente in denen es im studio plötzlich
ganz still wird weil das was wir ihnen
zeigen müssen kaum noch zu ertragen ist
aktuell ist johannes hano für uns in der
ukraine sein bericht jetzt am tag 100
wir sind unterwegs in der region nicolai
30 kilometer sind es bis zur front auf
den ersten blick ein friedliches
ländliches idylle im süden der ukraine
sie wollen verstehen was der krieg mit
den menschen macht viel haben sie hier
schon erlebt maria bode in einem
arbeitslager in graz geboren ihre eltern
von den nazis verschleppt
durch das alles schon einmal gegangen
als ich klein war ich hätte niemals
geglaubt dass ich am ende meines lebens
wieder einen solchen krieg erleben
in einer kleinen kreisstadt zeigt uns
der bürgermeister sich das leben der
menschen aus heiterem himmel mit einem
schlag ändert
auf 250 kilogramm in sein tier sei sein
fallschirm herunter gekommen sie haben
alles zerstört auch da hinten noch in
der nachbar siedlung sind die fenster
herausgeflogen
bomben terror gegen die zivilbevölkerung
in einem gemeindezentrum verteilen sich
hilfsgüter an die die fliehen konnten
aus den nachbardörfern dörfer die noch
immer von russischen truppen
kontrolliert werden ihr ganzes leben sei
ihnen genommen war
egal wie schwer es wird wir werden alles
wieder aufbauen wenn wir wieder
zurückkommen wir werden auf jeden fall
wieder zurückkommen
alle hoffnungen in ihre dörfer
zurückkehren zu können liegen auf den
schultern von männern beliebt
mit dieser haubitze aus sowjet beständen
wollen sie die russischen truppen
vertreiben aber igor wünscht sich er
hätte etwas besseres zur verfügung
ich traue mir davon jeden tag diese
waffen werden jedes jahr besser und
dieser bitte ist schon von 1986 total
veraltet und
er hofft dass er bald an den von
deutschland versprochenen haubitzen
ausgebildet wird
gummiteile und olga ist es heute ein
ganz besonderer tag micro hat sich extra
freigenommen von der front und auch sein
sohn andré jetzt mit ein paar kameraden
gekommen direkt aus dem gefecht um dem
vater zu gratulieren walter und so
kämpfen in der gleichen brigade an der
südfront
in diesen harten zeiten für die ukraine
wo es jeder tun was er kann und es ist
völlig okay wenn väter und söhne brüder
gemeinsam an der front kämpfen das zeigt
unsere einheit und unsere stärke
zur eigentlichen feier können andere und
seine freundin nicht bleiben sie werden
an der front gebracht
[Musik]
romy kairo ist es die zweite ehe sie sei
so froh dass sie wieder jemanden habe
der in ihrer seite stehe clark und olga
und das obwohl auch er bald zurück an
die front
es gibt für uns keinen anderen weg wir
werden ein starkes schönes und mächtiges
land werden
es ist die hoffnung und der wille
niemals aufzugeben was die menschen hier
zusammen hält auch 100 tage krieg
am ersten september 1939 gab es quer
über die gesamte titelseite der new york
times nur eine schlagzeile die deutsche
armee hat polen angegriffen der beginn
des zweiten weltkriegs 100 tage danach
hatte die zeitung bereits wieder andere
themen ganz vorne eine verbrecherjagd
und diverse sport- ergebnisse
nachlassendes interesse an einem thema
das mal alles überlagert dieses phänomen
ist so alt wie die menschheit es ist
selbstschutz sind urzeitliche prägungen
es kann aber auch in die falle führen
denn die herausforderungen sind ja
beileibe nicht bewältigt der bundestag
hat heute eine änderung des
grundgesetzes zugestimmt damit
milliardenschwere investitionen in die
bundeswehr fließen können nur ein
zeichen dafür wie grundlegend sich auch
unser land bereits verändert hat thomas
reich hat worum es geht heute im
bundestag dafür reicht ein blick auf die
tribüne die ukraine ist
parlamentspräsident im feld einzug des
militärs bekommt stehenden applaus
fast so viel zuspruch bekommt die
bundeswehr über der in zukunft hier
verhandelt wird das ist ein tag der
zeigt wie sehr das land sich verändert
hat seit olaf scholz auch die eigenen
leute mit einem sondervermögen
bundeswehr überrumpelte der
bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten die mittel
werden der für notwendige investitionen
gut drei monate später soll es
beschlossen werden mit den stimmen der
union und für das wie sonst hier
gerungen wird wie tief der einschnitt
geht sind sie sich schnell ziemlich nahe
gekommen
wir stellen 100 milliarden extra für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung
in einer sonder schuld das muss man auch
ehrlich sagen extra schuld kein extra
vermögen selbst die fdp ist dafür die
schuldenbremse per grundgesetzänderung
auszusetzen und auch die grünen ehemals
abrüstungs partei sind nun für mehr und
bessere waffen zähneknirschend etwas was
ihnen fehlt sind cyber sicherheit und
europäische zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
denn die defizite bei der bundeswehr
sind keine sekunde länger tragbar die
tornados seit 40 jahren im dienst werden
abgelöst durch moderne f-35 tarnkappen
bomber
auch der ch 53 transporthubschrauber
seit 50 jahren den einsatz wird ersetzt
durch neue c 47 chinook anschaffungen
die zum teil seit jahrzehnten
aufgeschoben wurden viel ändert sich
auch der blick zurück auf den nazi
militarismus der immer warnung war und
jetzt verpflichtung sein soll damals
wurde deutschlands militärische stärke
in europa befürchtet heute wird in
europa befürchtet dass deutschland
militärische defizite hat die hft ist
für die investitionen aber gegen die art
der finanzierung die linke lehnt das
paket insgesamt hat was könnte man alles
mit dem 100 milliarden machen verbergen
doch auch ein herz für kinder und wollen
gegen kinderarmut agiert warum gibt es
nicht da ein sondervermögen zur
bekämpfung von kinderarmut zweimal geht
es an diesem tag an die urne für die
grundgesetzänderung dann für die
einrichtung der 100 milliarden beiden
stimmt weit mehr als eine zwei drittel
mehrheit dafür es ist als besiegelt das
parlament nun scholz zeitenwende
der konfliktforscher und
sozialpsychologe andreas zick von der
uni bielefeld beschäftigt sich mit den
auswirkungen des krieges auf die
gesellschaft auch bei uns herr professor
guten abend sie nannte sie das
zeitenwende wir haben es gerade gehört
das ist der begriff ja dafür in der
politik was militärisch heißt haben wir
auch gerade gehört dafür gibt es relativ
klare vorstellungen und eine summe 100
milliarden aber darüber hinaus reicht es
denn so ein begriff einfach in den raum
zu werfen wie sehr ist zeitenwende für
die deutschen tatsächlich mit inhalt
gefüllt sein ich glaube es reicht nicht
aus wir müssen diesen begriff
zeitenwende im kontext sehen wo er wurde
er gesprochen am 27.2 dieses jahres und
der kanzler hat damals gesagt die
zeitenwende kam zustande durch den bruch
von verträgen durch die invasion durch
russlands angriff auf die ukraine durch
die einsetzung des krieges das heißt die
zeitenwende wende wurde eigentlich in
der rede von russland provoziert ich
glaube dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger
jetzt auch der meinung sind wir brauchen
jetzt eine selbst eigene aktive
zeitenwende und was hat scholz gesagt
damals hat der kanzler gesagt es geht
darum für ein freies für ein offenes für
ein gerechtes für ein friedliches europa
jetzt sich einzusetzen das sind fünf
zentrale elemente da geht es also um
freiheit da geht es um offenheit von
grenzen da geht es auch um fragen
zukünftig von migration um gerechtigkeit
da geht es auch um die frage von frieden
das ist ein baustein zur
friedenssicherung
und es geht um europa das sind fünf
riesen große projekte und zum anderen
müssen wir auch sehen wir haben in
anderen bereichen auch eine erwartung an
zeiten wenn wir haben das schon gehört
beim klimawandel
da kommt auf uns etwas zu wir sehen
soziale ungleichheit im land nimmt zu
wird sichtbarer und deswegen muss muss
es jetzt politisch als ein programm
gefüllt werden was ein weg in die
zukunft deutschlands in europa führt ich
nehme vielleicht erstmal das auf was ihn
gerade zum schluss gesagt haben diese
diese zeitenwende die ja noch viele
viele gefühl zumindest sehr viele andere
ganz große herausforderungen unserer
zeit umfasst sie haben aufgezählt
klimawandel corona diese konflikte
wirken irgendwie verschleppt geradezu
jetzt vom nächsten großen problem dem
krieg nämlich abgelöst ist so was gesund
für eine gesellschaft nein das ist da
nicht gesund wenn mir nicht konflikt
fest sind das heißt wir müssen
präventiver denken wir erleben viele
gesellschaftliche konflikte wir haben
die wirtschafts und finanzkrise erlebt
dann haben wir eine flucht zuwanderung
gehabt die schnell als krise erklärt
worden ist dann haben wir die kronen
corona erlebt und wir waren nicht gut
darauf eingestellt das heißt konflikte
die in dem moment wo kriseneinsätzen da
gerät eine gesellschaft in einen
konflikt modus wir haben erlebt ein
unheimliches erstarrten des populismus
der hat auch in die gesellschaft
hineingewirkt auch die politischen
auseinandersetzungen wurden
populistischer dass demokratie
misstrauen hat in deutschland auch
zugenommen im letzten jahr in unseren
studien so ungefähr 25 prozent sind eher
der meinung dass demokratie zu faulen
kompromissen führt wir haben erlebt dass
auch politik in der führung versucht hat
autoritärer
leistungsorientierter starke führung auf
diese autoritären elemente zu setzen
dann wir müssen wir wissen krisen werden
im auslauf einer krise da kommt es zu
konflikten auch wenn der krieg der noch
lange dauern wird dann zu neuen
konflikten führt weil er ist teuer und
die gesellschaften muss umgebaut werden
und europa und da müssen wir präventiver
denken das heißt präventiv jetzt an dem
populismus denken an den extremismus der
jetzt entsteht jetzt entsteht terror in
diesen zeiten daran denken dass politik
verständlicher wird das maßnahmen
erklärt werden
unter zeiten erlebt wenn politik
maßnahmen nicht frühzeitig gut erklärt
was kommt da auf uns zu dann ist das
wasser auf die mühlen von populismus und
extremismus daran müssen wir gerade
jetzt denken okay sie haben einen punkt
geht es gerade schon genannt man muss
offener sein vielmehr erklären bei der
ganzen geschichte transparenter
vielleicht auch sein jetzt haben wir die
negativen
punkte besprochen viele negative punkte
es gab aber und es gilt auch noch sehr
viel solidarität von den deutschen
gerade im hinblick auf die menschen die
fliehen mussten aus der ukraine
es gibt aber auch viel sorge in diesem
land was ist denn jetzt konkret nötig
damit diese zeitenwende am ende der
bessere zeiten bringt und zwar möglichst
für alle also ich glaube wir erleben
sehr deutlich dass bürgerinnen und
bürger beteiligt werden wollen das thema
bürgerbeteiligung ist tatsächlich auch
in europa ein großes thema prävention
von gewalt ist ein großes thema
sicherheit bedeutet eine starke
zivilgesellschaft die selber populismus
und extremismus in den griff bekommen
kann die politische kommunikation das
haben wir während der korona zeiten
erlebt die muss sehr viel transparenter
sein die muss deutlicher sender braucht
mehr da braucht auch politik mehr zeit
für das heißt wir brauchen dann auch
andere kommunikationsräume und wir
müssen etwas ernst nehmen wir leben in
zeiten der digitalisierung wo
verschwörungs information verschwörungs
glauben wo fake news falsch nachrichten
wo das doch sehr stark greift das war ja
auch heute thema im rahmen von cyber
sicherheit wir brauchen auch mehr
sicherheit gegen falsch nachrichten und
da können wir tatsächlich auf
bürgerinnen und bürger bauen denn die
zeigen ja in solchen krisenzeiten ein
enormes ehrenamt werden eine relativ
starke willkommenskultur und diese
willkommenskultur die wir erleben die
muss auch stabil bleiben die muss
gefördert werden und die kann überführt
werden in bürger-engagement das haben
wir gesehen während der flutkatastrophen
während der flucht zuwanderung als er
funktioniert etwas und das müssen wir
jetzt genau ermitteln wo etwas
funktioniert und die gesellschaft dann
konflikt fest machen das heißt auf neue
angriffe des extremismus und populismus
auch der krieg erzählt uns wie wirksam
selbst starts populismus und extremismus
wirken da können wir sehr viel mehr
erreichen da müssen wir nur daneben
zivilgesellschaft in besonderer weise
auch eben stärken enorm enorme
herausforderungen und enorm viel noch zu
tun herr professor hat sich den dank für
das gespräch professor andreas zick war
das von der uni bielefeld heute abend
live im heute journal ist dann gehen
und jetzt hanna hier bei uns mit
weiteren wichtigen nachrichten heute ja
der ukrainische parlamentspräsident
stefan tschök ist er aktuell zu gast in
deutschland und hat heute bundeskanzler
scholz getroffen bei einem gespräch im
kanzleramt forderte der fan shop von der
regierung mehr tempo bei der lieferung
der versprochenen waffen zudem lud er
bundeskanzler choice nach kiew ein zu
einer rede vor dem ukrainischen
parlaments die einladung habe scholz
freundlich zur kenntnis genommen
erklärte ein regierungssprecher
auf dem afrikanischen kontinent droht
eine katastrophale hungerkrise grund
dafür sind fehlende
getreideexporte wegen des ukraine kriegs
der präsident der afrikanischen union
senegals staatschef sei traf sich
deshalb heute mit russlands präsident
putin
konkret forderte soll die aufhebung der
russischen ausfuhr blockade an
ukrainischen helfen afrika sei der
situation völlig ausgeliefert russland
hingegen macht vor allem westliche
sanktionen für die fehlenden
getreideexporte verantwortlich
fast 400 96 milliarden euro so viel geld
darf der bund in diesem jahr ausgeben
den haushalt 2022 hat heute der
bundestag mit großer mehrheit
beschlossen wegen des angriffskriegs in
der ukraine unter corona pandemie sind
auch neue schulden in höhe von rund 139
milliarden euro vorgesehen dafür haben
die abgeordneten erneut die im
grundgesetz verankerte schuldenbremse
außer kraft gesetzt der bundestag hat
außerdem mit stimmen der ampel koalition
und der linken die erhöhung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns beschlossen ab
dem ersten oktober sollen
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
mindestens zwölf euro pro stunde
verdienen und dass arbeitsminister heil
sagte für viele sei dies der größte lohn
sprung ihres lebens mehr als sechs
millionen beschäftigte sollen davon
profitieren und mit dem mindestlohn
steigt auch die obergrenze für mini-jobs
und zwar von 450 auf 520 euro
und noch eine weitere entscheidung heute
im bundestag die für millionen menschen
im ruhestand wichtig ist die renten
steigen und das deutlich ab dem ersten
juli werden sie in westdeutschland um
5,35 prozent und im osten um 6,12
prozent erhöht
die innenministerien und minister von
bund und ländern wollen den zivil- und
katastrophenschutz ausbauen hiervor
fordern die länder mehr geld vom bund
nämlich zehn milliarden euro in den
nächsten zehn jahren in krisenfällen
soll in zukunft ein kompetenzzentrum die
koordination übernehmen und ressourcen
verteilen weiteres wichtiges thema des
treffens war der kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch dieser soll verstärkt
werden außerdem wurde beschlossen
missbrauchsdarstellungen künftig
schneller zu löschen
die regionalbahn ist voll besetzt es ist
schönes wetter ist es eine beliebte
ausflugsregion es ist der letzte
schultag vor den pfingstferien und dann
passiert ein unglück das jetzt dringend
geklärt werden muss der zug kippte
plötzlich um mindestens vier menschen
sterben in den waggons und viele werden
verletzt fragen gibt es nach so einem
schock immer diesmal sind es besonders
viele auch weil das unglück heute eine
traurige serie fortsetzt von den
schweren bahnunfällen der vergangenen
jahre passierten auffallend viele in
bayern simon pfanzelt jetzt mit mehr
es sind offenbar viele schulkinder im
zug als kurz nach 12 uhr das unglück
geschieht
schon zwei minuten später sind die
ersten rettungskräfte vor ort das leid
kaum zu fassen wenn man weiß dass man
bestimmte personen einfach nicht mehr
helfen kann weil es einfach vom material
her nicht geht und weil sie unter dem
zug eingeschlossen oder eingeklemmt sind
das ist schon fragt zu wissen dass
einfach nichts machen kannst die bahn
war erst wenige minuten in richtung
münchen unterwegs etwa 140 menschen
befanden sich im zug als mehrere waggons
aus den gleisen springen
mindestens vier menschen sterben 30
weitere werden verletzt zwölf personen
gelten am abend noch als vermisst
alleine vom rettungsdienst 120 fahrzeuge
230 einsatzkräfte acht hubschrauber tag
ab die feuerwehren waren mit hunderten
einsatzkräften da weil natürlich die
lage sehr unübersichtlich war
der zug sei einfach umgekippt berichtet
ein augenzeuge
es sei schrecklich gewesen warum es
passiert ist ist bislang unklar das sind
viele ermittler der
kriminalpolizeiinspektion hier also
unserem südlichen oberbayern beteiligt
die wurden auch alle alarmiert und die
ermittler sind sich im hirn unfallstelle
zu gange um die ersten erkenntnisse zu
sammeln um dann möglichst schnellen die
unfallursache klären zu können das
unglück wirft fragen auf die bilder
erinnern auf den ersten blick an den
bahnunfall in bad aibling wo im jahr
2016 zwei personenzüge kollidierten oder
an das unglück von schäftlarn wo vor
wenigen monaten zwei s-bahnen
aufeinanderprallten doch heute in
garmisch war kein zweiter zug beteiligt
die ermittlungen könnten langwierig
werden heißt es von der polizei
in berlin treten verkehrsminister
wissing und bahn chef lutz vor die
kameras die frage nach dem warum kann
dann auch sie heute nicht beantworten
wir sind in engem kontakt mit den
einsatzkräften vor ort und helfen wo wir
können unsere experten sind vor ort um
die unfallursache gemeinsam mit der
polizei zu ermitteln ich glaube heute
ist nicht der tag um spekulieren über
die unfallursachen das wird auch zu
arbeiten seien von den ermittelnden
behörden am abend besucht
bundesinnenministerium feser den
unglücksort informiert sich über die
bergungsarbeiten
die könnten noch einige tage andauern
und alle hier hoffen dass sich nicht
noch weitere tote unter den waggons
befinden
jaja oder sonne wald es für uns an der
unglücksstelle bei garmisch
partenkirchen guten abend jutta die
frage nach der ursache will man denn
eine antwort jetzt näher kommen und gibt
es bereits gründe die sich definitiv
ausschließen lassen
ja ausschließen lässt sich dass es hier
eine kollision mit einem anderen zug
denn die trasse auf der diese
regionalbahn unterwegs war ist
eingleisig zudem ist auf den
luftaufnahmen der polizei zu erkennen
dass es auf diesem streckenabschnitt
keine weichen gab
ausschließen tut die polizei auch dass
es hier einen anschlag gegeben haben
könnte zum beispiel im zusammenhang mit
dem g7-gipfel der ende des monats ganz
in der nähe auf schloss elmau
stattfinden wird
mögliche hinweise könnte der lokführer
geben der das zugunglück überlebt hat
doch ist nicht bekannt wie schwer und ob
er verletzt ist und ob er
vernehmungsfähig ist ein sonder
ermittlungsteam wird hier jetzt diesen
aus und leisten zug und auch diesen
streckenabschnitt den defekten
streckenabschnitt genauestens
untersuchen und bis es hier eine genaue
aussage gibt über die genaue
unfallursache könnten noch monate
vergehen heißt es mutter hat sich dann
für diese aktuelle informationen
ausgaben spart kirchen
und dann kommen wir jetzt nochmal auf
das große thema heute und auch dieser
sendung zurück 100 tage krieg jetzt mit
johanna aus der wirtschaftlichen
perspektive genau christian die antwort
der europäischen union auf den
russischen angriffskrieg die lautete ja
in den vergangenen wochen unter anderem
wirtschaftssanktionen und das sechste
paket inklusive weitgehendem öl embargo
das wurde heute formell von den
eu-staaten beschlossen die große frage
ist allerdings stephanie beckert in
frankfurt was bringen die sanktionen
überhaupt denn den krieg stoppen konnten
es ja nun bisher nicht so ist es also
die sanktionen treffen russland durchaus
vor allem aber eben die ganz normale
russische bevölkerung die kämpfe an
pfronten mit steigenden preisen und das
obwohl russland seit der krim sanktionen
in vielen bereichen bereits unabhängiger
ist doch nicht alle westlichen importe
können so schnell ersetzt werden und die
produktion bei lebensmitteln ging
hinterher nudeln brot und speiseöl sind
spürbar teurer geworden zucker kostet
über 40 prozent mehr als im vorjahr das
hohe preisniveau trifft auf ein eher
niedriges lohn und rentenniveau viele
russen arbeiten allerdings für den staat
und nehmen deshalb die entkopplung vom
westen nicht so negativ war mcdonald's
und fast alle bekannten marken haben das
land verlassen
verwaiste ladenzeilen bestimmen in
vielen russischen städten die
einkaufsmeilen zunehmend will man
westliche produkte durch russische
eigenmarken ersetzen dennoch russland
ist stark abhängig von importen und
ökonomen sind überzeugt die volle
schwere der sanktionen wird die
russische industrie es in einigen
monaten voll treffen schon jetzt leiden
besonders luftfahrt und autoindustrie
mangel weil teile fehlen werden
inzwischen die standards gesenkt in der
automobilbranche bei emissionen und
sicherheit auf airbags etwa verzichtet
man schon an den neuesten exportzahlen
der deutschen wirtschaft heute konnte
man die vorboten einer neuordnung des
welthandels ablesen während exporte in
die usa stetig wachsenden gehen die
ausfuhren nach china zurück und der
handel mit russland der minimiert sich
danke stephanie für diese einschätzungen
das vereinigte königreich feiert in
diesen tagen das 70-jährige
thronjubiläum von queen elizabeth der
zweite heute mit einem dankgottesdienst
in der londoner st paul's cathedral
doch die hauptperson die queen selbst
konnte nicht dabei sein wegen unwohlsein
ließ sich sie sich von ihrem sohn
charles vertreten aufsehen sorgten prinz
harry und seine frau megan sie waren
erstmals seit ihrem rückzug aus dem
königshaus wieder bei einem formellen
royalen anlass dabei
nun zum tennis und zum dramatischen
halbfinal aus für alexander zverev bei
den french open
gestoppt wurde der olympiasieger heute
allerdings nicht von seinem gegner
rafael nadal
schmerzhafter kann eine niederlage nicht
sein alexander zverev wollte in paris
zum zweiten mal in einem grand slam
finale einziehen und zum ersten mal ein
major-turnier gewinnen am ende musste er
das tat rollo garros auf krücken
verlassen zwei gegner nadal kann nun zum
vierzehnten mal die french open gewinnen
freut sich an seinem 36 geburtstag über
den finaleinzug und hat gleichzeitig
mitgefühl für seinen gegner ihnen der
kabine weinen zu sehen war ein brutaler
moment ich kann ihm und seinem team nur
das beste wünschen es wäre zeigte bis
zur aufgabe in einem hochklassigen spiel
eine topleistung im tie break des ersten
satzes hat er vier satzbälle doch nadal
gelingt beinahe unmögliches schließlich
gewinnt der spanier den tie-break mit 10
zu 8
auch im zweiten satz ein spiel auf
augenhöhe beide nehmen dem gegner
jeweils viermal das aufschlagspiel ab
bis es dann beim stand von 5 6 zu der
dramatischen szene kommt die für zverev
das aus bedeutete er knickt um wiegt
schreit vor schmerzen auf dem boden
[Applaus]
12 wird im rollstuhl vom platz gefahren
über art und schwere der verletzung ist
noch nichts bekannt nadal spielt im
finale gegen den norweger kaspar rüth
er hat zum mitleiden wirklich dass wir
unsere welt an diesem freitag und jetzt
empfehlen wir ihnen noch das
heute-journal update gegen 23 55 mit
nazan charakter im jahr bis morgen
hinein angenehm haben
[Musik]
guten abend dieses pfingsten wird ein
unwetter pfingsten und das hängt
zusammen mit tief südwestlich von uns
die brachten die ersten gewitter schon
heute mittag rot eingefärbt sind hier
die höchsten wolken und daran erkennen
sie ganz schön dass diese wolken schon
im wesentlichen aus deutschland
weggezogen sind in den vergangenen drei
stunden gab es aber noch kräftige
unwetter besonders hier an der grenze zu
tschechien
diese ist eine tief dass uns die
gewitter gebracht hat das sieht morgen
weiter nach osten dann beruhigt sich die
lage vorübergehend aber schon wird sich
über frankreich das nächste gewittertief
für den pfingstsonntag klar machen heute
nachweise gibt es noch letzte gewitter
und schauer im norden merken sie davon
nichts da ist es klar und wird auch kalt
bei 12 bis 6 grad milder bleibt die
nacht im süden und morgen erwarten uns
dann höchsttemperaturen an den küsten
von nord- und ostsee von 16 bis 20 grad
sonst werden 21 bis 27 an mittel und
oberrhein 28 bis 29 grad erreicht und
morgen wird der freundlichste tag dieses
pfingstwochenendes da gibt es allenfalls
dann am nachmittag einige schauer und
gewitter könnten vielleicht auch mal die
eifel treffen und dann kommt der
pfingstsonntag und damit breiten sich
kräftige unwetter mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen von westen über fast ganz
deutschland aus also wenn sie irgendwas
draußen vorhaben beobachten sie auf
jeden fall den himmel im nordosten
kommen diese gewitter nicht an da bei
der sphinx sonntag noch sehr sonnig
danach beruhigt sich die lage ganz
allmählich schönen abend noch